c'est un projet imaginé l'an dernier et
qui s'est enfin concrétisé côté la
rainure
[Musique]
cité
tikok vellaye en résidence au petit
conservatoire de l'est s'est pris au jeu
de l'écriture accompagné de ses petits
artistes de l'école de comptes de lille
qui chante la musique ce pays c'est pas
une majorité curieux spectacle et qui
vont tous serbe locale ils ont un choisi
l'artiste viennent à l'école on
travaille avec les isoler de la liasse
il a composé cinq chansons avec cinq
classes différentes
il ya le concert hillary sont là ils
participent vraiment et chante avec
l'artiste ya vraiment un moment de
partage avec c'était trop bien j'ai bien
aimé tu comme et l'ail
nous avons comme médaille d'or c'était
bien et je me suis bien amusé et une
énergie débordante
ces élèves de la maternelle au primaire
accompagne l'artiste et ses musiciens
tout naturellement
deux communes portant sur le cachemire
tout ça maintenant mes chantiers
incroyable a ajouté la génération le
temps la flamme des jo 2020
donc les super tout ce super ça c'est
toujours le fruit du travail qu'on me
dit mais en même temps aussi c'est la
force de tous les jeunes ont besoin s'en
fait une bouffée d'oxygène bien mérité
dans le contexte actuel dit à l'évacuer
un peu ça fait du bien au moral
dans ce contexte actuel ça fait du bien
d'oublier de s'amuser un grand bien si
atypique détail en tout cas c'est super
d'autres récréation musicale devrait
être programmée prochainement une
demande des artistes et bien évidemment
des enfants